good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy monday i hope
everyone's having a great day they have
risen they have grinden and they have
toasting
sure i think that's
12 18.
i think so too hi claudia how are you
i'm scared to ask because last time i
saw you we were all together and it was
a joyous occasion and now it not only is
it a monday we're separated
no more flamingos i painted over them i
do that every week when you leave i i
just put new ones create a new mural i
put new wallpaper over new wallpaper i
thought you and harry were drawing it by
hand
i miss the flamingos i'm looking at them
right now and they're like what about us
we only got four days what about us
by the way can i tell you that
i've noticed you making a conscious
effort to audibly laugh more
i haven't been making an effort but my
laugh evolves
it's constantly changing it used to be a
cackle then of course i go to the tea
kettle during pregnancy my laugh
definitely changed i think that's when
it really became like silent crazy yeah
uh but i do want to laugh more audibly
because the podcast listeners just think
i'm a humorless [ __ ] a humorless wench
when she oh
when she oh well you were being a wench
yesterday when um
you stayed in florida and i came back
here and you were being a bigger wench
when you left my house
um sorry jackie that i am a literal like
best-selling comedian and i have to come
back i have a show in new jersey on
thursday tickets available at girl no
job.com tour very few seats left um so
that's why i'm back like i'm not back
for naught
it just it doesn't i'm glad for you that
you're a best-selling comedian thank you
really doesn't make it hurt any less no
i completely agree like it doesn't make
it hurt any less that you moving to
florida was the right decision for your
family yeah but it still hurts
yeah
that's so true
so true so sorry about that but we're
separated again and this time it was
really tough because i think i spoke
about last time how i was like so upset
to be leaving but i had a trip planned
the next week
currently
i have no trips planned
no which is so sad and scary i do hope
that you come like once more and then
i'm coming to new york in september i
have so many things to do so many new
york tings well i'm not like a planner
you know i like wake up and i'm like i
think i'll go to florida for the week
yeah what if i just went to florida what
if i just bought a ticket
what if you just
right so it's okay that i don't have
anything planned because i'm sure i'll
be there soon
yeah and then i'll be in new york and we
have so many fun things planned so here
we go then also you have fashion week
coming up i don't know right right like
thinking of fashion week i guess like in
some other universe i should time my
trip to new york with fashion week but
no i'll be there the following week no
you should time your trip
opposite fashion no but like
you're clear but all the influencers
like they come to new york in september
like they're coming for fashion week
there's events there's this there's
shows and just for me um
it's going to be the following week
yeah no that makes sense that's like
coming to new york during the un general
assembly like it's suggested there's
traffic you also need to play the trip i
need to check those dates yeah the
general assembly the city turns upside
down you should come here that week
get out of dodge i gotta get out of
dodge um but it really was a glorious
weekend together i miss you already i
miss harry
so much like truly the hardest goodbye
is the kids like i couldn't even look at
you guys i was just like oh my god
michaela and how are you like truly what
are they gonna do without me
yeah i think it's really hard because
obviously like you and i facetime you
and i text like i know how you feel but
when you can't communicate with these
kids yet
it's hard to like let them know like i'm
going but i love you and we'll call and
we'll text and like we'll catch up it's
just like sometimes when a few times
zach has had to travel with bruno and
it's like yes zach i'm going to miss you
but like i can text you i can call you
we will communicate brew
where's mommy no and like in their mind
bruno and the other nibblings it's like
oh auntie is abandoning but it's like no
actually i don't live here i was being
kind by coming here you know but you
could live in my house if you want to
the room is yours by the way now that
i've checked out
five keys
five keys for all it was a glorious stay
five stars all around
great bedding great privacy you know
nobody was really like entering my room
which i appreciated great vibes great
fan great lighting great blinds great
mirrors great closet space
really great proximity to the kitchen
that's huge mm-hmm
good stuff
keys
i mean maybe like 4.7 keys because of
the air conditioning situation but
that's more harry's fault than it is
yours i can't wait for him to grow up
and be like mom my room is so hot like
crank up the ac trying to do push-ups
mom i'm trying to do push-ups like can i
get some air
okay maybe next time he'll be ready for
some more ac but we'll look into that
for you i'm sorry that it wasn't a
five-key true experience no you know
what
because of the lack of air conditioning
i had to get myself a fan and that fan
kind of like changed my life like
curling my hair with a fan on is next
[ __ ] it's like camp
it's like camp but for me every day is
like camp like whenever i'm doing my
hair i'm just sweating and i gotta get
like a
like a standing fan for my vanity
because i hate getting awful clamped
while getting ready it's like
counter-intuitive yeah it is
counterintuitive honestly so many things
about moving down here feel like camp
like i really haven't left the house a
lot of the few times that i have it
really feels like i i have a period off
that's funny yesterday and olivia and i
like we made a plan a few days ago to
get manicures because both of our nails
were decrepit i hadn't had a manicure
since new york i think it was like five
weeks total and olivia i don't know the
last time she had a manicure so we
got our period off yesterday and we got
manicures and pedicures and we're just
new women at least you guys like have an
excuse for being decrepit you know you
have actual children who rely on you for
survival um i'm just decrepid period i
just can't believe you don't have a
manicure
in new york i feel like you were doing
it like out of solidarity with us
for sure for sure no because it's like
we were all supposed to get manicures
together like every day in florida like
if we ever had had time we would have
gotten manicures
so the thing is is like i have spent
three out of the last four weeks in
florida and right before i left for
the first trip i was like oh i need to
get a manicure and then i'm like wait no
that'll be like a fun thing to do with
the aunties like we'll all go sisters
manicure trip and then it's like oh you
guys are too busy with you know
your children to get manicures and i
really kind of experienced the
sacrifices of motherhood
um so now i'm just left manicureless
yeah you got to take care of that for
your big show i know and you know what
else i have stumbled upon facial tic toc
specifically this one place dallas med
spa um i was up for an hour last night
watching their asmr hydrafacials first
of all when you go to dallas since you
go sometimes you have to go like okay it
looks like such a premium experience
they do derm um this is not sponsored
like they just have like a it's like
this random one spa that has a huge
presence on tick tock and it makes me
i'm like in search for a really good
hydro facial i want to get dermaplaned
and that's kind of on my priority and i
need a haircut
yeah the place where i get my facials
that you don't like
they do hydrafacials that's why i go no
i know jackie was like i got a
hydrafacial this was like a year ago
maybe more no it was more because it was
when cameron wescott came on the toast
oh wow so like three years ago yeah but
you know what happened actually so she
came on the toes and we were like how do
you look so amazing she's like i get
hydrafacials so then like hydrafacial
reached out to me because i said like oh
my god i want that and they gave me like
a store locator and they were like just
pick any one of these places and then
you'll go there so i just chose one that
you personally didn't like maybe they'll
reach out to you and you could choose a
different one okay jackie went to this
place she was like it's amazing i go
it's literally this forlorn closet
in the back of a spot it was
like
you're so particular and very you have
like high standards for everything so
jackie says the place is great i'm like
oh this is going to be fun i said the
facial was great i didn't say the place
was great the place
was
unique
i said the facial was great it wasn't
you know
guerlain
i wanted
to
i wanted all okay those facials from
those spas are enjoyable
they're they don't do anything they put
on cream they take it off they put it
right there
they put on a warm towelette they take
it off they wash your face yeah a hotel
spa is not gonna give you a gorgeous
facial you need to go like a med spa or
like a real facial place but i also want
like a massage the luxury some crystals
they were doing like crystals like i
want that plus like a good [ __ ]
facial yeah you know who you should ask
who aside from hoping hide your facial
retention i'm just hoping like a
premiere that's why i brought it up i'm
like i just need someone to tell me like
what's the best facial i'll go i just
need to know where okay but if no one
tells you you should ask skinny
confidential
oh that's actually such a good question
i wonder always getting a glorious
facial i wonder if she knows about
dallas med spa
i wonder but she definitely knows of a
good place in new york which is sad
because you live there but no like the
way i'm about to book a flight to go get
a facial at this place you have to go
okay maybe we could go together one day
we'll add it to the list of big dreams
oh speaking of big dreams that came to
fruition jackie and i finally saw elvis
yes you ain't nothing but a hound dog
you ain't no friend of mine
[Music]
welcome to diners drive-ins and dives i
just discovered that the theme song for
diners drive-ins and dives is the very
end of hound dog
[Music]
there's a guy fieri and we're rolling
out taking you on america's greatest
diners drive-ins and dives that are
beautiful stunning and smart
um and i have to say
the movie is totally like living up to
the hype it was really really good
especially um austin butler i think
austin butler was definitely living up
to the hype um and i was surprised there
wasn't a bigger conversation around the
crime that was committed by tom hanks's
presence in the film he was literally
atrocious he made me almost want to stop
watching especially because he was just
as much of a main character as elvis was
and just conceptually like the movie
being told from his point of view not my
favorite stylistic choice i would have
made different choices but choices were
made and tom hanks literally
he needs a break like from acting i need
a break from him he needs a break from
the work because he's obviously lost his
touch his accent as a dutch person i'm
surprised there's not a petition going
around holland it was so [ __ ]
offensive
god forbid they just get like a actual
dutch person because i think of all the
accents like dutch is very difficult
like i get it
tom hanks has neither the skill nor the
talent that he thinks he possesses
because that accent was giving like
halloweentown it was so bad he was so
bad and i think part of it was his
character was like this [ __ ] so like
you were set out to hate him already but
tom hanks did such a bad job i cannot
believe that that is one of the most
critically acclaimed actors of our time
um he's obviously lost his touch
he is nothing of the sort he ruined the
movie dead ass
and i just think he owes us all an
apology
wow
hottest take yet and i i don't even
think it's hot i think everyone agrees
oh i haven't seen any really reviews i
actually when i was googling elvis the
man after the movie just because i loved
the movie i enjoyed it thoroughly but it
made me feel like i know nothing about
elvis because i mean i didn't know a lot
about elvis but then you watch a biopic
and you expect like okay i got the gist
i finished the movie and i was like
what happened with elvis like i just
feel like
they told like his story in a way that
really made sense and a lot of things
like didn't add up whereas i'm sure in
like real life they added up like for me
i didn't understand why he leaned so
heavily on this big ugly loser colonel
tom parker when he had like a really
stable and loving home life like that's
just typically not how it goes but
clearly there was something about his
home life that left him open to this
vulnerability for this like big loser to
take advantage of him
make him join the circus even though he
already had upwards momentum in the
music industry like that i'm sure in
real life like obviously it made sense
that's what happened but it didn't make
sense to me as you know a novice and a
lay person it made me want to read like
a biography about elvis to get the
actual facts but it definitely spiked my
curiosity in elvis i'm just like
i know he's like the actual goat
but i just feel like he's kind of
underrated
okay let me say this
my one and only true gripe with the film
like if i were to talk to baz bazlerman
a lot of things weren't adding up
because my takeaway if i had never heard
of elvis in my life
my takeaway would have been oh elvis is
a big fat loser like he's a failure he
sucks nothing he did ever really like
mounted to anything huge he had so many
like so much momentum like false starts
so i if you would have asked me if i
never heard of him i said uh i don't
think people would be talking about
elvis in the next 20 30 years that was
the takeaway from the like the movies
were good but then they stunk the tour
was almost great but then he went back
to vegas so everything was just like
failure failure failure and i'm sure
like anyone elvis's life was filled with
highs lows you know successes and
failures but the movie just and i think
this was really supposed to be educating
like a younger demographic on elvis and
i won't be surprised if the younger
generation thinks elvis was a big fat
failure like yeah and i would have
thought that i mean at the end they do
say he sold more solo units than anyone
of all time which is like i didn't get
any of that from the movie anytime he
was having success it was literally a
30-second montage until the next failure
and i agree i'm like oh so this guy
never made it he literally never met
left the country he just like stayed in
vegas and as he said he like was playing
in a mausoleum every single night and
it just made you think like this man
lived and it was very sad and he was
very successful
plus then not
world available but like was colonel tom
parker right about the fact that those
world tours would have cost so much like
can someone just like tell us some facts
yeah there was a lot of context missing
especially as it pertained to like money
yeah and just numbers and success and it
just seemed like oh elvis had some
momentum they shut him down they sent
him to the army he came back but he was
sad and then he did movies but the
movies were lame i feel like they never
really captured the magnitude of his
success like especially the movies the
movies is the perfect example like his
early work and yes eventually he did so
many movies like then it was just a
factory and they weren't but in the
beginning like there was a period where
he was like the biggest movie star doing
really serious acting roles like they
just glazed over the huge cultural
impact he had when he had it and just
jumped and i know that they were
covering 42 years
in the i know it was a lot
and that's why it was a three-hour movie
but i still don't feel like they really
accurately painted a picture of what his
career was
yeah i agree and like some of his movies
i don't know if they said it in the sh
in the movie or i researched it after
but like love me tender is a serious
movie like viva las vegas i know that
movie
uh
and i feel like he has so many more hits
that he didn't sing and
i just felt like they missed the
magnitude of elvis but i loved the movie
i'm having a renaissance
with elvis hot oh my god
so hot it's just so talented so
interesting priscilla oh my god and
she's from the society and i just love
and i ship and like and and then all of
us they were so in love they were so
rock solid we never saw him with another
woman all of a sudden he's kissing his
fans he's [ __ ] other girls and
priscilla's leaving and she knew about
other girls yes like so much context was
missing yeah and it's like did elvis
ever have another love like i don't know
anything
such a good point
um and i loved that you really got to
oh and
there were a couple things they didn't
touch on one like the fact that
priscilla was literally 14. whatever he
was 24. let's not talk about it um the
other thing was like elvis's jewish
roots like they meant they
kind of alluded to it
once at the beginning when they just
showed him wearing a jewish star but
like elvis was jewish
for safety
and believe in god exactly in his
childhood he didn't um
wasn't publicly jewish i think you know
it wasn't a great time to be a jew
um is it ever
and he was very proudly jewish in his
career none of that was spoken about um
so i just felt like there were like core
pieces of his life
that were
just kind of glazed over
yeah i agree but overall so good austin
butler so good i don't even know that
much about elvis or watch him but like
the silhouette of him the mannerisms
like sometimes it really
and especially when it was far away like
it really looked like elvis i do feel
like in some scenes they actually fused
their faces together with some sort of
cgi when it was further away
but just like the shoulders the walk the
costumes it was it was amazing it was
really amazing and
it was nothing short of amazing it just
then piqued my curiosity like now about
elvis so if anybody has any elvis
documentaries or books just i just need
one i just want to understand more about
the man and i just felt like his
personality was missing too like the
movie made him seem like a big loser
when he is literally like the coolest
man on the planet right he was obviously
like extremely outspoken and principled
like especially when it came to like the
bobby kennedy thing and the civil rights
movement so he wasn't this like shy
doormat like he had
a voice but then when it came to the
colonel and maybe that's how it was i
just would have liked to understand more
how you he could have been both people
you know yeah and how he could be so
under the colonel spell when
it seemed like he was a you know a whole
person
yeah and this guy's a literal like clown
from the circus oh girl from the circus
hot rubber song and we said this while
we were watching it but what the [ __ ]
was the snow and the snowmen snowman the
snowman and the showman like i guess you
know tom parker made it snow
and
did snow mean money they never have no
idea i thought rain was money seriously
i really think tom hanks like he has
more money than god
he needs a serious break from acting
he's obviously overworked he's losing
his
losing it yeah the star quality i also
think and i'm usually not one of these
people who's like if the person doesn't
look like the character they shouldn't
play the character but the amount of
prosthetics that they had to put on him
to make him into it was distracting no
and honestly like he's
i'm like at this current moment in time
he's not a skilled enough actor for the
job like i'm sorry he couldn't do the
accent
and you know who i kept thinking and he
also it doesn't come off
evil like you can't
you like you can't be andy from toy
story
and forest like he just doesn't have the
range to be all of them there are some
actors who are inherently evil who's the
guy you know the guy the nazi
christopher kristoff waltz
he should and he could do dutch i know
it his german accent was perfect maybe
he might be german actually i don't even
know that's how good the accent was yeah
tom hanks is too recognizable it just it
was not a good call sorry
not sorry
yeah i i agree with that i mean maybe
the
they wanted you to like he should be
this like affable guy that you think is
you know in elvis's corner that's
probably how elvis felt about him like
this father figure and he's just not
that he's nothing of the sort whatever
they were going for didn't work austin
butler was incredible deserves an oscar
nomination perhaps the oscar tom hanks
deserves a rousey
and that's why the movie was so good
because it had both range
um i also am officially all caught up in
real housewives of beverly hills and
starting this week i will get back to
the recaps i put up on my instagram
story my full thoughts because they're
like
they required a lot of fleshing out so
if you're interested in like
a really detailed analysis of beverly
hills feel free to go over to my
instagram story however
um what i will say is that i
i would take a bullet for garcelle like
i
am abs like obsession doesn't even begin
and you know who's really um i think
becoming obsessed with garcelle too like
just drinking up her energy andy kathy
hilton ooh
and these two queens together laughing
about homeless not toothless
was one of the highlights of my life not
laughing at the organization just the
name and darite was getting like so
butthurt about everyone just they
accidentally kept calling it toothless
not homeless
and or no
yeah yeah see they're they were just
having trouble like
it was so funny and now
i think i read somewhere that like the
the charities being investigated for
misappropriating funds
which is just great
for the community um
it was it was a boring episode but it's
just so crazy how lisa rinna
in a matter of like maybe a year has
turned into the biggest villain and it's
clearly intentional she i think has
started to use this show as like a
marketing machine because this week was
a rin of beauty event um and she was
being her unhinged self as usual um when
it comes to something that she
is behind you know like her rina rose
now it's the rin of beauty it's giving
like low budget everything lisa rinna
does aside from like her behavior on the
show where actually just
she doesn't really she's not acting like
a good housewife anymore but for beverly
hills being this like really elite rich
like all these events she's throwing rin
of beauty rina rose like everything is
just giving low-budget energy um and
it's giving real housewives of orange
county energy and i just think the
franchise is above a lot of this
stuff
i don't think there really is a place
for lisa rinna any longer and honestly
kind of erica too because erica
she used to be all that with the glamour
but also all that with the drama yeah
and just the personality like the
confessionals the ones
now her confessionals her one-liners are
so dark and like not
kind of funny
her life isn't doesn't have that glamour
and like her only real
contribution to the storyline is being
mean to sutton and that's kind of what
everyone joins the show and they're like
i'm going to be mean to sutton and think
that it makes me interesting and i'm
here to tell you that it doesn't
actually makes you look like a bully and
honestly i don't know how sutton
maintains her friendship with kyle
because the way that like everyone snaps
at sutton in an instant and says like
loki really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and then
moves on
the way that no one defends sutton
except for garcelle and garcelle gets
[ __ ] on for defending her if that was me
if i was sudden i would cry at every
single event like even the smallest
things that don't become story lines are
so [ __ ] mean yeah i can't like and
sutton is no perfect housewife but she's
getting like the villain wrath
yeah no she's like a nice person she's
just quirky she's just different and
kind of weird but um there's so much
injustice happening on real housewives
of beverly hills it's making it like
infuriating to watch
that injustice can do that yeah
injustice can do that
so it's a little tv recap we've got a
great show
five stories
it was the weekend so we got some juicy
ones
yeah then we have unburdened yourselves
and they're quite
quite shameful are they quite onerous
burdensome what's onerous mean
burdensome
they're quite burdensome you're going to
cringe especially from the last one yeah
it's big yikes energy
okay well i guess without further ado
and without further talk about elvis it
is time for the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
ollie lollipop a new kind of soda tastes
just like the sodas we grew up with but
unlike other sodas that are full of
sugar corn syrup and artificial
ingredients like aspartame lollipop is
made with natural ingredients that are
actually good for you they have amazing
nostalgic flavors like vintage cola
classic root beer orange squeeze cherry
vanilla strawberry vanilla and their
newest flavor classic grape so i told
you guys that i was really trying to cut
back on soda
lollipop has been really helpful for
that because there's
so many good flavors that taste really
similar to like iconic soda flavors
i i'm obviously into the classic vintage
cola because that's kind of my vice of
choice um they're really good they're
good for you it's a great substitute and
if you're looking to cut down on soda
you're just looking for a delicious
beverage you know to have with your
lunch check out lollipop that uses
functional ingredients that combine the
benefits of prebiotics plant fiber and
botanicals to support your microbiome
and benefit digestive health the vintage
cola has just two grams of sugar
compared to a regular coke which has 39
grams the orange squeeze has 5 grams of
sugar orange fanta has 44 grams of sugar
their products are non-gmo vegan paleo
keto friendly and they have less than 8
grams net carbs per can you can receive
20 off plus free shipping on your order
when you go to drink olliepop.com
toast or you can just use code toast at
checkout to get the deal that's
d-r-i-n-k-o-l-i-p-o-p.com
toast for 20 off plus free shipping on
your order lollipop can also be found in
over 8 000 stores across the country
including walmart target kroger whole
foods sprouts and publix you know we are
pub girlies
today's episode is also brought to you
by ziprecruiter there's so many more
things to do during the summer and you
want to free up as much time as possible
to enjoy them so if you're a business
owner the last thing you want to do is
sort through tons of unqualified
candidates resumes
cover letters when you could be i don't
know by the pool at the beach spending
time with your family that's why you
need ziprecruiter to get great
candidates they're doing the work for
you and now you can try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
toast so here's how it works they'll use
their powerful technology to find and
match the right candidates up with your
job you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply they have a
complete suite of tools that makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates four out of five employers
who post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day we have
used a recruiter for years if you're
looking to hire anyone for your business
or any sort of role in your life check
out zip recruiter it is by far the
easiest and most effective way
to hire soak up all that summer has to
offer and let zip recruiter do the work
for you go to ziprecruiter.com toast and
that's where you can try it for free
again that's
ziprecruiter.com t-o-a-s-t
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
thank you mccleardia
you're welcome
yeah
welcome
are you ready for our first story the
big news of the weekend love is in the
air ben affleck and j.lo got married
this weekend with their big
big wedding their old hollywood themed
wedding at his 8.9 million dollar state
in georgia where guests enjoyed cigars
and beautiful scenery she was wearing a
ralph lauren gown daily mail has the
intimate photos of the
venue also there was a sign that said
let me jennifer and ben baby i love you
heart and soul let's get loud
oh i [ __ ] love a reference to let's
get loud the greatest song on earth
catch me at about mitzvah like losing my
mind to that song um
something about ben and jen is extremely
chewy
yeah
they are giving chugi energy um and i
love that for them i think it's like
extremely appropriate especially for jlo
she definitely like in her personal life
exudes chugi energy
um however i have become so fatigued
with these two like i couldn't give less
of a [ __ ]
except i do find it really interesting
that you wore ralph lauren um and i kind
of think it's really appropriate because
in a way these two are like
america's sweethearts like they were at
one point
um you know she's just a girl from the
bronx he's just a boy from boston like
they really are um
that and they were when they were
younger so i would have thought she
would have worn i feel like she has a
really good relationship with like
versace obviously because of the dress i
feel like she did like a valentino
campaign i feel like she could have worn
a lot of different designers and i'm
sure anyone would have wanted to work
with her and i never would have guessed
ralph lauren but i don't know it's
georgia like
shh it kind of makes sense yeah she also
wore ralph lauren for the vegas nuptials
that pretty dress
so it's just a ralph lauren moment for
her i agree it is kind of surprising i
could see it being like versace imagine
if she wore like the green dress but in
white right right like for but she does
no she doesn't want that she just wants
classic you know because everything
she's like traditional everything about
this wedding is just like
pinterest
yeah you know you choose your aesthetic
and and that's what you get it's they're
not trying to be
different
or too cool they're just i mean like two
people in love celebrating love what is
more chewy than getting married on a
house that is plantation style yeah that
i mean come on did we learn nothing from
blake lively and ryan reynolds like
but it's his house it's his house uh he
tried to sell it a few years ago
8.9 million dollars but he didn't it's
87 acres
and i guess it just became the perfect
venue for for their love story
and it was a plantation
okay they say it's plantation inspire i
think it's plantation inspired i don't
know that it was ever a working
plantation
that like i think we should be like you
know
like who would be glorifying a
plantation like that's honestly [ __ ]
weird yeah
yikes it's a big yikes it's a big yikes
and this will come back to haunt them it
did blake lively and ryan reynolds it
will jlo and ben but i also feel like
even though i'm becoming so fatigued
with these two i also feel like there
wasn't a lot of hoopla around this
wedding they weren't releasing like
people magazine all the photos daily
mail has is from some freak hanging from
a helicopter yeah well there was a
no-fly zone over the wedding so like we
really don't have wedding pictures daily
mail has like pictures of the interior
of the house it looks like pictures from
when like the houses are on the market
when the house was on the market and
like here are some of the pictures of
the basement no it's giving realtor.com
yeah they really don't have and daily
mail is the only place that has pictures
like every other publication just has
like red carpet photos of ben and jen i
feel like in a few days we will get the
real photos at on the jlo newsletter
oh you don't think it's going to be a
vogue exclusive
no i really i think it's going to be on
the jlo exclusive and you should
subscribe okay hold on because i
unsubscribed she's constantly
subscribing in and out of on the jlo so
when she put the announcement on okay on
the j lo
i subscribed when she put the engagement
announcement then i'm like wait i missed
the engagement announcement so then i
unsubscribed
now let me resubscribe on the jlo she's
got great seo she comes up first let me
put in my email
so you'll be the first to know
somebody like never check my email i'm
all signed up check your email for
regular updates on news special
experiences exclusive content and more
from jlo
you do
we need that exclusive content today
also notably your favorite person in the
world casey affleck wasn't there ben's
brother why is he my favorite person in
the world because you love the lobster
he was in the lobster right
let me tell you if casey affleck came
and farted in my mouth i would have no
[ __ ] idea who he was like he gets
talked about like just as much as ben
mostly because he's like a controversial
um freak
but
uh when i tell you i'm sorry to this man
i have no clue what he looks like was he
in the lobster no
oh who was in the lobster i feel like it
was russell crowe colin farrell same
thing literally
crying i don't know why i thought he was
i'm like please don't slander my name
casey affleck has been accused of
horrendous things he's not my favorite
person claudia loves casey he's just
like one of those guys for her she's
shut up can't quit him jackie please
stop lying
anyways he wasn't there which is weird
they're brothers
are they even close i think so but he
posted on his instagram apparently like
parental obligations kept him at home
which is very possible but he posted an
instagram a throwback picture of himself
and jen saying good things are worth
waiting for here's to twists and turns
new beginnings and finding new
reservoirs of old love that's actually
kind of sweet welcome to the family get
ready for some real dysfunction kidding
i am kidding jen you are a gem we love
you so much red heart emoji
okay so you're telling me casey affleck
couldn't find a babysitter i'm telling
you jlo told him to stay home like for
real because of like his he's like
radioactive he's been accused of like
horrible things doing horrible things to
women i'm sure jlo is like get the [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] away hold on stay away from
this plantation
we have our own problems over here casey
affleck
scandal
yeah sorry i i know that there's a big
one and i don't remember what it is
that's why i keep being vague he was
accused of sexual misconduct on the set
of his mockumentary back in 2010.
two women sued the actor for sexual
harassment
like i said from the set of that got it
so um
i always forget that they're related i
always thought for but for a while i
thought it was just a coincidence that
they both had the name affleckt
yeah but i guess it's not a coincidence
there can only be one affleck in this
town they don't look alike
no not at all whatever the reason he
didn't show up i'm sure jlo was
extremely grateful whether she had
something to do with it or not
yeah for sure it would have just
overshadowed
the whole thing oh i don't know i think
honestly the fact that he's not there
kind of not overshadows whatsoever but
it's like a whole other article where
was casey affleck um right
i don't think she cared either way what
celebrities you think were there i was
thinking that this morning matt damon
for sure
leah remini for
sure yes her friendship with jayla was
like my favorite thing it's her favorite
thing too she's always posting about it
on social media i would do the same if
jayla was my best friend did you watch
shayla's documentary um
so i don't know like her other close
friends because she's like friendly with
kim but i don't think close enough for
this what seems relatively intimate
wedding yeah it was giving friends and
family
yeah but it was like 400k it was a big
actually that's what i like
says but i feel like it was more
yes just some security alone a celebrity
yeah security well they didn't have to
pay for the venue
or the dress probably yeah they probably
got a lot of free tings
chugi
[Laughter]
um also story one subset b in wedding
news sarah highland and wells adams got
married this weekend
of modern family
showed up and showed out they were
married at sunstone winery near santa
barbara california
on saturday
which bachelor peeps were there i saw
sophia vergara julie bowen like the
whole crew was there from modern family
so just tell me if sofia vergara was
like with you know chase mcnairy like
who was there you know
i don't know which bachelor people were
there it's like not in the article and i
haven't i didn't see anything from
bachelor nation i only saw from modern
family socials
yeah me too by the way that's how i knew
they got married i saw a selfie of like
the crew
yeah no but i need to know if sofia
vergara was at a table with chase mcnary
you know like that's just like what i
find in crescent
about these two as a couple they have
been together engaged forever
a three-year engagement you know i think
at any point people were like are they
are aren't they i think just like
they were really coveted couple yeah
and they waited till they could do it
really big and i'm really happy for them
that they're married i'm happy for them
too i think it's cute
um
love to see people from bachelor nation
moving on up in this world
and i'm wishing them a lifetime of
happiness
me as well but i do need to know which
bachelor people were there i feel like
there were not a lot like just the
closest to friends like wells is pretty
good friends with
nick viall right
oh good question
and what about chris harrison
interesting
i guess we'll they'll do a people
exclusive you know oh for sure i'll keep
keep your people notifications turn them
back on oh my god
i can't with their notifications i know
you couldn't take one more breaking news
recipe from the pioneer no and they're
always throwing queen elizabeth's name
into
a breaking news thing you can't do that
to people yeah because they want you to
like oh my god and then tap it and
realize no she's not dead she just
doesn't have the same color hunter boots
as jennifer garner
so sick taking advantage of our time
also jennifer garner was spotted like
out marketing this weekend good for her
i i feel like she is an unbothered queen
honestly like i think the end of her
marriage with ben affleck
was so horrendous i think she had a
boyfriend
like while he was you know out getting
help and their marriage was ending and i
think all she wanted was for it to be
over so she could be with her mans
i think she's bothered
maybe there's like a little bit of body
i think she's a woman
because it's jlo if it were any other
person on the planet unbothered but
right because the one person that could
hurt her no not even hurt her does that
invalidate their whole relationship
no
but one could think that it does if
you're spiraling you know
yeah i think she's bothered but she
her image is very
premium
premium so she's not gonna show herself
being bothered whatsoever no she is like
a tear of celebrity um very successful
acting career behind her she gives mogul
energy now i know she's like an investor
in a lot of those like
mom brands that are organic you know
grass-fed bottle-fed
things oh i gotta check it out but also
she's just adored and her brand is very
smiley happy lovey and you know being
bothered by her ex's new relationship is
not on brand so
we'll never get
any sort of indication but how could you
not be you know she's from an era of
movies like rom-coms things like that um
that
remind me of jessica beale
and i feel like if somebody doesn't say
jessica biel's name every six months i
will forget that she is alive yeah
where is she
i don't know i don't know if she like
works a lot or maybe she's just being a
mom
yeah
it just makes you think i literally
forget she exists like once a week no
like once
a month i guess she is similar to
jessica garner like that time but
jessica garner kind of also reminds me
of like sandra bullock
who reminds me of julia roberts no
sandra bullock and julia roberts i think
are like uh
they have been nominated for oscars you
know jennifer gardner jessica beale
like they were in that like rom-com type
of would you say cameron diaz
no she's in a league of heron i agree i
[ __ ] love that woman
i really do yeah does she have a book
she needs a book that's a memoir i would
read
she needs a book when i think of cameron
diaz i think of catherine heigl
they were both they were both in that
rom-com scene but the queen
but cameron diaz was before katherine
heigl
yes but i think in terms of similar
careers
i agree
the highest paid actresses for a long
period of time without being at the
oscars yep
but their movies have a lasting impact
on our culture and on our hearts and
minds yeah
yeah
okay so that's all the wedding news from
the weekend are you ready for our next
story switching gears yes ma'am scott
disick's lamborghini suv flips over in a
terrifying single car crash
scott disick's a lamborghini suv flipped
over in a car crash on sunday the
talentless founder sustained a minor cut
to his head tmz reported that doesn't
sound good
the talentless founder well
the founder is a good title
yeah but it sounds like he's a founder
with no talent not the founder of a
company called talentless capital t
makes all the difference that's why
capitalization is everything kids that's
why grammar is important conjunction
junction what's your function
claudia it's a little early for these
oh yeah take your top off
conjunction
you know who would have sounded so good
singing conjunction you ain't nothing
but a
yeah
big mama thornton i get it
fraud not frog play i get it i will
continue to sing frog
yeah frog is really fun but anyways
elvis would have
murdered conjunction junction 100
literally at the international
no not elvis
elvis oh i was saying big mama thornton
oh
i was seeing elvis but they both would
have killed it killed it
conjunction junction what's your
function
anyways
scott disick uh sustained a minor cut to
his head but refused medical attention
at the scene of the accident in la the
wreck involved only his car with a
source telling the site that speed
appeared to have played a role in the
flip photos obtained by tmz show his
lamborghini on its side just a few feet
away from a destroyed stone mailbox in a
ritzy neighborhood
the single car crash occurred around 3
p.m pacific in calabasas and no arrests
were made as a result
a source told the outlet that scott did
not seem impaired at the scene he did
not receive a ticket or citation of any
kind and he has not publicly commented
on the incident
is this giving like a little
nefariousness a little just like a
little bit speed racer right three
o'clock in a residential neighborhood
broad daylight what what the [ __ ] are
you speeding for
what the [ __ ] are you doing
right especially like
because a lot of this sounds like anne h
like driving in a residential
neighborhood in the middle of the day
going too fast
no it doesn't sound apples to apples
because like she crashed no but like a
lot of the details are reminiscent yeah
and you would think like after that just
happened everyone would be on like high
alert
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing but no he should stop it and he
just has like a nefarious nature to him
yeah
at least it was only like
one car involved i mean i hope like he's
okay and it sounds like he's fine and
if if he wasn't speeding or doing
anything then it sounds like he could
have a lawsuit on his hands
right with from lamborghini
well also um that's just the weird thing
about car crashes like this how like you
can
like a car can be flipped and the person
can get out totally unscathed or dead
yeah it's so weird
yeah i just saw a headline this morning
about like this
family the parents died their ford f-150
flipped over and the the roof of it
crunched like as if they were they might
as well have been in a convertible and
they were awarded 1.7 billion dollars by
ford that's why i'm saying as i showed
this could be a lawsuit if the car
malfunctioned right right
no but that's like ben's friend pete was
in an accident you should have seen the
car jackie was completely totaled he's
fine
it's crazy it's like how is it so one or
the other the parents were killed in
that forbidden f1 right right that's why
it's so important to wear seatbelt
honestly
yeah
well i'm hoping scott's okay but if he
declined medical attention
hopefully he's fine yeah
totally are you ready for our next story
which is so crazy considering the news
of last week well not so i mean i don't
want to
overhype it it's just interesting
okay is it the overhyped slush not
overhyped like interesting story that's
brought to you by first leaf yes cause
you're gonna want a glass of wine after
hearing this do you like to unwind with
our podcast and a nice glass of wine
well first leaf is making it simple to
discover new wines that you will love
they learn your tastes then they deliver
quality wines right to your door forget
driving to the wine shop and forget
shopping by the label and forget
overspending on bottles you don't like
with first leaf you rate each wine you
receive with a simple thumbs up or
thumbs down and then their experts will
send you personalized selections with
new and exciting bottles in every box
they can recommend wines you'll love
with a 96 accuracy so as your taste
evolves so will the wines that you
receive so i love to drink wine i know
nary a thing about wine i just know what
i like and i know what i don't like i
don't know any of the words i don't know
any brands so a company like first leaf
is great
it's also a great price to constantly be
stocked on wine you know that you're
there's a 96 chance that you're gonna
like it i think those are pretty good
odds and if you're not completely
satisfied with a bottle they will credit
you for another at first leaf it's wine
made simple sign up today and you'll get
your first six bottles for 39.95 plus
free shipping that is six bottles of
wine for under forty dollars go to try
first leaf dot com slash toast that's t
r y f i r s t l e a f dot com slash
toast to get your first six bottles for
39.95 plus free shipping try first leaf
dot com slash toast
great
thank you um so
love is love it's dead you guys because
i was blind star dangle rule filed for
divorce from nick thompson so danielle
and nick from season two of love is
blind we're the other couple that got
married this season we were just talking
about the first couple to announce her
divorce last week ayanna and jarrett and
we said like oh danielle and nick are
still going strong and they probably
always will um but then they she fell
for divorce and i just feel like each
couple didn't want to be the first and
danielle and nick held out as long as
they could and then when ayanna and
jarrett pulled the plug they were like
great now you know we weren't the first
i think that the show makes you stay
married for a decent amount of time
maybe a year
and that
like uh time restriction recently came
up and that's why we're hearing about
both divorces in we in the span of one
week
you really think that they can make them
stay married
no but i think that they can
force them not to announce that they've
gotten married until a certain amount of
time has passed okay interesting so you
think that all these couples broke up
like a while ago
on their own timelines but i don't think
that they've been married up until last
week in in a romantic sense at least wow
maybe conspiracy
maybe legally they have been married but
separated
living totally separate lives you know
what i feel like danielle nick ayanna
jared are since they are reality stars
they were you know once regular people
and i feel like they have like friends
out there like if anyone knows why these
couples split up can you yeah i'm just
curious because like we i feel like we
really got to know that we really get to
know them as much as you possibly can on
a reality show you see like the good the
bad the ugly of their relationships and
i did feel like these two couples even
though i could tell you what their
issues were you know like he's this way
she's this way we're different but
opposites attract and they worked
through it and i just like want to know
at the end of the day
what came between them what was it was
it was it the dancing on tables was it
the costumes in the apartment the thing
is is that i agree with what you're
saying as it pertains to nick and
danielle i don't think that jared and
ayanna were ever really a good match
yeah but i think that they just really
liked each other but sometimes you have
to ask yourself is love enough that's
blind that should be the next show like
love is blind we're questioning whether
or not love is blind
love is enough
yeah love is blind but is it enough
no sometimes it's not like that's what
happens when you you know fall in love
with someone in this like
vacuum fake vacuum right then you go
back to real life and it's like we got
bills to pay we have things to do that
happens on the bachelor all the time
it's easy to fall in love with someone
living in a mansion someone else is
paying for yeah
yeah then schedules and families like
life relationships are hard mm-hmm so
it's easy to have like an attraction to
someone and have a relationship flourish
in a world with no real consequences but
then you go back
to your smelly apartment and shit's not
the same
yeah
especially when the apartment is smelly
of course and with nick and danielle
like i did find this genuinely shocking
um and if i had to guess just based on
what i know about them um
why their relationship ended
i i would have to assume it has a lot to
do with danielle because nick was like
all in accepted her for who she was and
she just like could not
believe that somebody wanted to marry
her and loved her yeah and she was like
self-sabotaging she was
but he was a little
i don't know i have to go back and watch
but i just felt like he was
a little particular i do feel like this
definitely kind of chips at the
credibility of the show that was my next
question because we're two for two on
season one we're over two on season two
does that mean we're neutral and love is
blind is you know equally as successful
as it is unsuccessful
i don't know
like the thing that really kind of set
it apart from all these other shows even
shows on netflix the bachelor love
island is that the first round like we
got two really strong marriages
and by the way even if one of those
couples from season one now would get
divorced i would still consider it a
success yes i agree
but i do feel like these two but you
know what there was a lot going on in
the world at that time coveted changed a
lot of things for a lot of people maybe
i can consider it a blank slate maybe i
need one more season to make my decision
i agree
for me twice shame on me right
yeah we shall see
we shall
see we shall
see we shall thank you claudia also love
is officially dead with our next story
i just want everyone to
prepare for this terrible news that
olivia gianouli and jacob allure they
have broken up i know
um olivia jade gianouli and jacob
already have reportedly called it quits
after a few months of enjoying each
other's company and being like so cute
and candid in his sweatshirts and in his
socks
the pair enjoyed spending time together
says a source um but ultimately didn't
want to be tied down to one another
olivia is now single and having fun
quote and quote living it up with her
friends while uh euphoria's star jacob
allordy is quote completely focused on
continuing to build his acting career
quote he's not looking for a serious
relationship at the moment
but he added that the couple hung out
earlier this summer and are not
currently dating
so i feel like you don't have to
delegitimize the whole relationship just
because you guys broke up and now you
need to be like we were never dating
like do you understand this for some of
us this is all we had like for some of
us this is life or death yeah like you
don't have to [ __ ] all over it okay it
didn't work out don't say like it was
never that serious or the baby out with
the bath water even if that's true like
i don't think there was one person out
there who wasn't like here for this
relationship so just let us live the
dream still let me just say this even
though i loved the two of them together
the vibes that i get from jacob lordy is
that he's like really serious and like
is obsessed with acting and art and like
kind of boring for someone so
yeah it's like annoying
so um
in a way while these were two were so
perfectly matched in terms of like looks
and also like
careers and vibes i think on a
personality level like i think olivia
jade is a good time gal i think she's
really fun
funny
um and i think he's like takes himself
really seriously almost to a fault like
i could see him just like going to the
movies you know on a date and like
crying afterwards like bringing a
notebook and a pen yeah like he's kind
of like a downer but i think he will
have a very long illustrious career but
i think i think he's probably not like
the most fun person on the planet to
date like i don't think he goes out to
clubs i've actually never seen him at a
party like yeah i agree restaurant i
think olivia's like living life and
right you know he's focused on his craft
and that's like is love enough is being
so good looking and suited for one
another and cute enough like no not if
you have different interests not if you
have different priorities no but i do
think this relationship was great
because it brought olivia jade like into
this young hollywood kind of social
circle and i'm very i'm excited i'm
thrilled i'm overjoyed to see where this
journey will take her who will she date
next like of course austin butler comes
to mind because kaya gerber of it all
used to date jacob now dates awesome
there's just this kind of pool of very
young very good looking very successful
i would throw like zendaya in there like
really um like a fabulous tree
i know i hear what you're saying yes but
she used like was spotted with jacob and
lordy like they're all kind of connected
and now olivia's in that crew and i
think it's very exciting for her
potential new suitors and i'm excited it
is exciting i'm going to add her to the
list i'm going to add jacob to the list
and let's see if there's anyone on there
that we already think okay good for her
and age appropriate because i believe
she's about 23. chris evans
too old uh shawn mendes
done done
signed sealed delivered that is cute
that is cute and age-appropriate i think
he's like 28 29.
yeah
great maybe jacob alordian oh no addison
ray is like in a really serious
relationship
i don't know why she's on this list
oh yeah that's a good call i just love
her i want to put her on every list
me too and like i'm really feeling for
her i know you're not like totally
abreast on what's going on but her
father
needs to he's continuing to make waves
and he was just recently i saw a picture
of him making up this girl
and she's like this influencer her name
is ava louise she like was one who liked
the toilet bowl at the start of covid
remember
okay she's also the one who like made up
the rumors about kanye west and
jeffree star like she's like a
professional troll and she's
has had like public beef with addison
she's like kind of like i think bullied
addison online and now her dad is like
making out with her like he's i couldn't
afford to after she looked at the toilet
i could vomit no he's really like being
a complete disgrace and and i've i think
everyone has always had a weird feeling
about him the way he kind of
wrote his daughter's coattails like
under the guise of protecting her like
yeah i'm going to move to la with you to
protect you from this
very colonel tom parker
yeah i wouldn't be surprised if he was
stealing from her honestly yeah for
for sure
i just i love addison i miss her and
she's having an amazing time in italy it
looks like i hope i saw she was in tel
aviv
no way i think her boyfriend cause then
i was thinking why she in tel aviv her
boyfriend's name is like omar or omer
which kind of gives like israeli vibes
yes israeli
is omer so he's was the drummer for
mgk or travis i have literally no idea
who this man is okay no he's not a
drummer sorry but he's in the band with
one of them
no clue
but they're on tour and omer's in italy
and tel aviv with addison
i have no idea
makes you think
okay well um thinking of olivia jaden
jacob lordy oh and i just wanted to go
on a tangent because it reminded me just
talking about like prominent young male
actors when after we watched elvis i was
we were doing some more deep dives and i
was reading articles about all the
people who were up for the role
obviously we know harry styles we really
wanted the part boz was like no it's
austin you're too hairy for this role
but also who auditioned for the role and
was close to getting it was miles teller
and ansel elgort and even though austin
butler was perfection and the role was
meant for him and it was meant to be his
like i do think miles teller would have
done any crayon job
does miles sing
i could see him
say carrying a tune i could see it
okay because i think that's important
that was like a a fun fact about austin
butler that i didn't know um and the
thing let me tell you why austin butler
was perfect for it and the only reason i
don't know
if miles would have been good for it
part of the reason why austin butler was
so good is one because
to most people he's a nobody so his face
was totally unrecognizable and you could
really see him as elvis miles is the
biggest movie star in the world
currently
secondly
austin butler had literally nothing
going on he was able to study elvis for
three years because he was pretty much
an out of work actor
miles teller is booked busy on the books
he couldn't just like
be a recluse and he has like a wife and
a family like he couldn't just you know
fall off the face of the earth for three
years to study all of elvis's hand
gestures and facial mannerisms only
someone with no life could have done
that like austin butler and now it paid
off for him in spades and he will have a
life moving forward he's got a
girlfriend he's got all these things now
but before that he was like a nobody
with no life and it was perfect
that is a very good point i agree i just
i actually think that if you did him all
up miles teller actually looks more like
elvis than
austin butler
but
that's fine also i'm sure i'm sure at
the time like miles was bummed to lose
the role i imagine you know it's the
role a million girls would kill for but
i think at the same time that this was
being shot so was top gun maverick
because they're out around the same time
and like miles was meant to be on the
beach in top gun maverick so i'm sure
now he's like everything happens for a
reason like i was meant for this but
it's nice for miles to know that no
matter how it went like he was going to
be topping the box office charts no
matter what yeah no it's nice to see
everyone got what they wanted
yeah because it's the one you got
because it's the one you got yeah
also do you remember do you remember
when austin butler was in australia in
the beginning of filming this movie he
had just broken up with vanessa hudgins
then he was spotted like canoodling with
olivia deganj who is priscilla in the
movie and she's also from the society
she spoiler makes the poison pie and
i don't know if i realized at the time
that she was going to be priscilla and
like so they were actually
getting romantic while they were filming
which i think gives the movie an extra
of a je ne sais quoi
but of course if austin butler is method
acting he has to romance priscilla
wait can i tell so true by the way can i
tell you who also popped into my mind is
like a potential um
good like maybe at a certain point in
time he would have been good i don't
think he's tall enough
um but i think like
maybe like if the movie had been made
five or six years ago zac efron would
have been a great
he's so musically talented um he's such
a good dancer
um and he can carry a franchise
now i think he might have aged out of
being like a good candidate but he
definitely comes to mind as someone who
his name was definitely like tossed in
for even a brief moment i
i love zac efron like i always have the
more time that passes i love him more
and more i love his projects i love his
career he doesn't have elvis's build and
for that reason like i don't think i
could see it
but i just watched trailer for the new
movie he has coming out called the
greatest beer run ever yum and it looks
so good
and i just love zac efron i love zac
efron too
he's so talented and this movie looks so
good i can't wait to see it he's a p
john of all p johns and i have nothing
but respect for him especially after
what he did with greatest showman
yeah
you just love him i could talk about him
all day
no me too maybe we should do a patreon
episode all about zac efron i would love
that i would love it because i just need
to be reminded of all his good work yeah
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's like really crazy okay
aubry o'day has been accused of
photoshopping herself into influencers
photos belief with this story i saw it
on tick tock somebody had all the side
by sides of aubry's instagram versus
like the pictures she allegedly
photoshopped herself into
i'm obsessed
yes
also obsessed with this leading line
from page six another o'day another
photoshop scandal involving aubry o'day
so a little over a year ago the former
danny kane member announced she was
leaving the u.s to start a new life
abroad she found herself in some hot
water for flooding her newly private
instagram feed with allegedly altered
vocation photos the pictures in question
which began occupying space on the
singer's grid immediately after her july
2020 move show the blonde bombshell
posing seductively on unbelievably
perfect beaches wearing body clinging
cut out clothing in lush rainforests and
holding vigorous yoga poses on top of
picturesque rocks according to o'day's
geotags almost all of the images were
taken in bali however social media users
aren't buying it a tick tock user whose
name is sophie believes the pop star
went on this vacation around bali just
by just photoshopping herself into
pictures it's truly like every single
picture sophie noted as several of
oday's posts flashed across the screen i
don't even know if she went to indonesia
like at all if you look at the pictures
they're perfect photos and then aubry is
copy and pasted onto the photo they are
so photoshopped like obviously they're
edited if she even is on a swing in bali
but it really looks like
she's not the lighting is so off and
these like from the picture of her to
the background picture like
she's not there
where
it is unclear if she ever actually made
it to the airport to go to bali because
she did she did not take these pictures
herself they are all photoshopped like
she's like google images and then just
like canva pro put aubry in bali and
this is like one of the most
embarrassing things that can happen to a
celebrity do you remember when shane
mitchell got called out and for me like
shane mitchell has accomplished so much
i think base her
travel line is so successful the stuff
is so cute but i will always remember
that one thing about her it's like the
most embarrassing thing that a celebrity
can be accused of
yeah i think there's two social media
fall pause one taking a picture from
google images or from another influencer
and like passing it off as you know your
own there's a difference between like
yes you're posting and be like inspired
you know i love this vibe like and then
you know obviously but acting as if
that's where you are when you're not and
you're just like home sitting on your
couch
is yikes and also i forgot who it was
who did this when it's like you're on a
commercial plane but you're like
pretending like it's private
oh bow wow
i remember that too see those things
stick with you because it's so
embarrassing
it's
mortification at its finest but the
thing is with aubrey o'day like
i don't think her brand is gonna suffer
that much because i don't think her
brand is that
special yeah no i think it's fine
honestly it's great that she's in the
news i think it's hilarious but what
makes what compounds the story are the
captions here's a here's a quote from
you know her in front of a green screen
i believe if we embrace complexity and
its layered conflicting existence we
become more free
free from manipulation free from needing
to control others behaviors to make us
happy free from the stories we make up
to explain the things that do not come
simply most of the time there's no clear
answer
here wait clarity is in the complexity
put that on canva pro the quicker you
desire and embrace this idea of clarity
versus viewing it as a singular
destination the closer you will get to
flowing in your natural current
okay so when i when you look up word
salad in the dictionary
this is it like that's just a bunch of
words put together that mean
zero nada 100 like these are like
celebrity buzz words like
piece complex construct layer the closer
you will get to flowing in your natural
current
the [ __ ] does that mean
seriously i don't know but i want to
flow in my natural current
you know what i think i'm going to do
this weekend
flowing my natural current yeah i love
that for you i think you'll really find
clarity in the complexity
anyways this is where embarrassments are
wherever you are aubry i i thank you for
the joy that this story has brought
where in the world is aubrey oh day
literally like did she ever go to bali
this off the grid life if she went to
bali she would at least have her own
photos of bali that she could put
herself into that's something but when
people can find you know the original
photo the influencer who you super
impose yourself like this is a whole new
level it's just so unreal and it's so
dumb because she's geotagging the
locations that these other influencers
have posted at so it's really not hard
for people to find the original photo
that she copied
yeah i'm surprised i want to put this
together sooner like i guess there's
something people wake up every day and
think about aubrey o'day no but like if
some like if kim kardashian posted one
of these pictures people would be like
girl you photo like she can't even post
a picture and swap out stormy for true
and people like
match up the outfits and they're like
the lighting on this one is off like she
wasn't actually there and they were
right
you know if she really superimposed
herself into a destination
but
well that's the difference between aubry
o'day and kim kardashian seriously like
nobody cares about aubry otay
and that's why it took weeks for people
to realize she never went to bali and
all of her photos were fake but it's
like over a year if it started in june
2021 okay so like that's further proof
of how irrelevant she is honestly and
that's that's really sad honestly that
makes me sad maybe it was if i was
aubrey this is how i would play this if
aubry's pr is listening like i wanted to
see like how i wanted to show how fake
social media is
and from the pictures to the caption is
fake too and nobody called it out for
over a year and that's on you guys and
you guys are fools yeah and she'll say
like i've actually been filming this
whole thing for like a documentary and
the documentary never comes up like
nobody remembers it was a social
experiment right yeah and welcome
um so those are the past five it is
monday which means we're doing unburden
yourselves which is our monday segment
where people write in embarrassing
things that happened to them in the last
week and we just kind of help alleviate
that burden we're gonna take it on for
you and you can officially set it free
um so anything from work to
friends
anything you can write into unburden
yourselves
at gmail.com it's in burden yourselves
gmail.com i don't know if they
understand yourself
and it is brought to you by upside from
cringing at the pump to getting an
eye-popping check at your favorite
restaurant inflation is hitting us all
where it hurts and it really hurts
that's why we have started using upside
an incredible app for anyone who talks
to who anyone who buys gas groceries or
dines out with every purchase we are
earning cash back thanks to upside the
app is so easy to use and it doesn't
have this like too good to be true
element like it really
works like a no-brainer
you'll get all this cash back and you
can use it on anything personally i'll
probably use it on food but like it's up
to you
to get started download the download the
free upside app and you can use our
promo code tmt5 that's tmt the number
five and get five dollars or more cash
back on your first purchase of ten
dollars or more next you can claim an
offer for whatever you're buying on
upside check in at the business pay as
usual with a credit card or debit card
and just get paid in comparison to
credit card rewards or loyalty programs
you can earn three times more cap cash
back with upside they are earning users
more than a million dollars a week they
have a 4.8 star rating on the app store
it's a no-brainer for you it is easy get
cash back have your money work for you
it's just like a premium experience
without you having to do much which is
my favorite download the free upside app
and use promo code tmt5 to get five
dollars or more cash back on your first
purchase of ten dollars or more that's
five dollars or more cash back on your
first purchase of ten dollars or more
using promo code tmt5 all right ready to
unburden some peeps ready
hello jackson claude
a few weeks ago i took the bar exam the
testing center was far away from my
house so i had to stay in a hotel the
whole two days were really stressful and
overwhelming to say the least at the end
of the day i went to go get dinner and
went back to my room i was looking at my
phone so i didn't pay attention to where
the elevator got left me off so i went
to what i thought was my room and i
tried to use my room key it didn't work
and instead a woman opened the door and
looked at me confused if it was any
other normal time i would have
apologized and realized that i was on
the wrong floor but because i was so
unwell from the stress of the bar exam i
thought that she was in my room i
legitimately argued with her that she
was in my room she said she wasn't and
shut the door to which i knocked again
and again and told her she was in my
[ __ ] room
she then closed the door on me and i
heard her say to someone in the room
some girl thinks this is her room what
the [ __ ] eventually someone waiting for
the elevator nearby overheard asked if i
needed help and then explained what
flora was on i was so embarrassed and i
cannot stop thinking about it
here's the thing why you don't need to
feel any sort of like stress about this
you'll literally never see this woman
again that's why hotels are great you
know
everyone is just a stranger passing in
the night literally you'll never see
this woman again who don't think two
thoughts of it but you've also gifted
this woman like everyone has a funny
story about a hotel like ben one time at
a wedding there was another guest at the
wedding named ben sawfir but spelled
s-o-f-e-r we were all staying at the
same hotel ben's flight was delayed
we're all at the shabbat dinner for the
wedding ben goes into ben and mira
saufer's room takes a shower
um gets out of the shower goes into the
bathroom on the counter it's like all
these cosmetics but like for like an
older woman they're they're an older
couple and ben knows like my makeup he i
have the same kind of pouches that i
bring with me and it's at that point
that he realizes naked um while in this
other person's bathroom that he's in the
wrong room thankfully we were all at um
the shabbat dinner and nobody saw it but
and by the way any time we were at the
meet and greet in florida someone came
up they were like oh my cousin ben and
mira software like
they love it they know where the story
is
so funny everyone has a hotel story that
like is their drink like their dinner
table story so you gave them that they
should be grateful you'll never see them
again no harm no foul no harm no foul
like yeah if it were me i would think
back on it and cringe like you really
thought you were so right and it's just
funny like you weren't but it's really
not a big deal it's not like you did
anything
horrible aside from arguing you know
insisting it's your room it's not like
you barged in you know whatever
i think it's totally fine it's just
really funny and congrats on taking the
bar like yeah don't let that you know
awkward moment override this huge
success in your life mazel tov
mazel tov that's what we should be
saying
there is nothing wrong with that like
it's totally fine it's just like an
awkward thing but it's funny
all right second up hello jackson claude
hey i am mortified and i need to end my
burden
last week in a small group meeting i had
to share my screen to review some
content uh-oh whenever
i literally i'm shuddering at screen
sharing is so horrible
whenever i share my screen i'm always
sure to only share a specific browser or
application instead of the whole screen
for privacy purposes
during the meeting i messaged my
co-worker to vent about someone in the
meeting no well unbeknownst to me i was
sharing my entire screen
and the person
and everyone else in the meeting saw the
whole conversation the worst part was
that i was bitching about the person
multitasking while i was speaking while
i was clearly doing the same thing the
person i was venting about pulled me
aside after the meeting to discuss what
they saw and was extremely kind and
reasonable about the situation
nothing extremely nefarious was said and
i apologize profusely but i still want
to crawl into a hole and die
in these situations you have to think
about how much worse it could have been
you could have said this [ __ ] ugly
wrench and her disgusting smelly breath
like the things you really think of her
thank god you were only complaining
about like something kind of fair you
felt disrespected yes it could have been
so much worse and honestly if it was any
worse like you actually would have to
leave the company this is that would be
so horrible i'm in so much pain but you
know what you were just like
being like a workplace karen like she's
multicast whatever it's fine it's not a
big deal it could have been worse and i
just need we all need to use this as an
opportunity to learn from this because
if you're listening to this episode like
this cannot happen to anyone ever again
let us it won't be a mistake if the
hundreds of thousands of millions of
people listening right now learn from
this and we all double check when we're
sharing our screens yeah and when our
screen is being shared like don't be
doing anything anything
even if you only shared chrome you
should make sure that email message
slack everything is shut down until your
share is off yeah i don't do anything
that you would share don't do anything
that you wouldn't want the whole room
seeing if in that meeting if at any
point in the meeting you are screen
sharing because obviously one mistakes
happen but two sometimes technology gets
a mind of its own all of a sudden
your texts are on the tv so if you are
ever screen sharing in a meeting please
let this be a lesson do not do anything
else all you think about is everyone
seeing all of the things on your
computer
during the meeting thank you a hundred
percent and so to this girl
it could have been worse but everyone
listening take this as a warning and for
the person that has happened to we need
to thank you
for giving us cause to issue this
morning so thank you you've done us a
public service while it could have even
been worse for you so at the end of the
day everything's okay you've done a
great service to your fellow toasters
and we are in your debt
we are okay
hello jack's claude ross and stress and
you're saying this one is more onerous
than the last one oh i don't know if i
can handle it this one's pretty bad
over the weekend i dragged my boyfriend
and some other friends to go to a strip
club with me i had never been to one and
honestly i just wanted to check it out
we had so much fun and the girls were so
nice
when we had when we had first got into
the club i had taken a cute like
aesthetic instagram story picture of the
ceiling lights and i added a location
sticker a few hours later i pulled my
phone out and i realized that i
accidentally put my cute strip club
picture on my company's instagram story
i manage it i have access to it and i
posted it instead of on my personal
instagram
my boss thought it was funny but i am
still mortified please help unburden
this extreme screw-up sincerely a social
media manager who will now double-check
which account she posts anything to for
the rest of time
again these are things that have to be
learned the hard way i have worked
before this i worked in social media
many times and i i had you know run-ins
like this it was only a few seconds and
it certainly wasn't at a strip club but
it has to happen to you
in order for it to never happen again
um i think some workarounds around this
are requesting a work phone i don't know
if you should really be blending you
know your private and your
corporate lives i think having a
separate phone or even like an ipad
would really help this situation
i agree i was gonna say separate phone i
mean it totally depends on what kind of
company you work for because oh i could
see a lot of companies like okay so the
social media manager or the brand voice
was out like celebrating women at a
strip club like okay like not the
craziest thing ever but there are some
where it would be like really clear that
someone's horrible offense that someone
[ __ ] up here so i mean as long as
you're not in trouble at work it's not a
big deal agreed this is something that
needs to be learned the hard way and
every social media manager has their
story i mean this you always have to
think
it could be worse the person who runs
the pope's instagram
the person who always think about if
you're ever like in a snag at work think
about the person who liked um bikini
model photos from the pope's instagram
but he was obviously just doing it on
his personal or on his finsta so you
think you [ __ ] up at work you've never
[ __ ] up at work like that on a global
scale where there was a full
investigation from the vatican as to who
liked the photos so you know what could
be worse
could be worse and again we will use
this as an opportunity to issue a
warning to all the social media managers
out there who have all their accounts on
one phone who do like to go to the strip
clubs and take aesthetic photos of the
ceiling at least it was like an
aesthetic photo of the ceiling and not
like you and your friends like big tips
in your face
yeah bottles at the blurb
yeah yeah
um this should be a lesson but i think
it's always really important to remember
how things could be worse and then of
course when you zoom out from the
perspective of the big bang theory this
is nothing
nothing you guys are going to be okay
all of you i appreciate you sharing your
burdens um
you should be grateful to your boss by
the way because like she didn't make a
big deal of it so therefore it's not a
big deal and we can forget about it yeah
and now collectively we all
can
release these burdens into the ethers
they are no longer going to weigh us
down we start this week with a fresh
slate a tabula rasa go forth and prosper
and learn from these mistakes that way
they are not mistakes
and now that you are done listening to
this episode today is the premiere day
for the very first episode of good guys
josh peck and ben's new podcast good
guys which is available everywhere their
first episode just dropped it's called
teetering on diabetes and that should
really give you like a good
sense of what the episode includes they
also tried to do some pop culture news
and like i was crying ben literally they
were talking about the royals and ben
literally thought prince charles was
dead
he knows nothing it was so funny the
episode is great it's available now
wherever you get your podcast so we hope
you enjoyed this one we hope you'll
enjoy that one
i think you'll enjoy all of them and
we're going to get you through the day
till we're back tomorrow morning for to
whose day
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcasts can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitcher
public video i have radio cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find out some morning toast
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an enclave monday rides
grind and we'll see you tomorrow goodbye